now to the coronavirus pandemic and the
huge effort to vaccinate as many
americans as possible the reported death
toll
has reached 399 000 in the u.s
and is almost certain to pass 400 000
later today
the latest cdc data shows less than half
of all available vaccine doses
have been given to patients states are
working hard to change that
our lead national correspondent david
begno is in lansing michigan david
how's michigan's vaccination effort
going
anthony they've used about half their
vaccine so far that's the vaccines that
they have received
sparrow health system here in the
lansing area actually secured this old
sears
center this is where you come to get
your oil changed but this morning
you just drive up and get a covered test
they've already tested 100 000 people
and starting today just this morning
what they did
was they opened the two closest bays to
where we are to start vaccinating people
first time they're doing it right here
this is what's happening all around the
country
hospital systems are finding whatever
space they can find to get the job done
from amusement parks to arena parking
lots even livestock event centers
there are vaccine supersites popping up
all over the country
wherever there's room cases and
hospitalizations are on the decline
nationally
but with more infectious variants
spreading in at least 20 different
states right now
don't expect cases to drop too low warns
infectious disease expert michael
osterholm
this is what i think is extremely
concerning and why this race we have
between the virus and the variants
and the vaccine administration right now
is so critical
getting the vaccine to underserved
communities is also critical
and that is what dr richard bates is
doing here in michigan
usually twice a week dr bates loads a
cooler full of vaccines in his pickup
truck
and he drives about two and a half hours
north to a hospital in rural alpena
where they're immediately administered
that's because the alpena facility
doesn't have the freezers
that are needed to store the vials so
from the moment he drops them off they
have
five days to use them i need to be there
for the clinic
it's my community and i'll go bates is
now a hospital administrator at mid
michigan health
but before that he was an ob gyn right
here in alpena
after delivering babies for more than 25
years
he says the joy of delivering vaccines
is the same
seeing the look on people's faces just
like i did when i
handed off newborn babies you know baby
that was
hope and dreams and all those sorts of
things so it's the same
feeling you know there are still pockets
of extreme spread around the country
take california
they've had three million cases thus far
in california
the la area they actually have their own
variant you've heard of the variant from
the uk well la's got its own variant
that is spreading like wildfire there
there are so many people dying just in
los angeles county gail
that they actually relaxed their air
quality restrictions
so they could do more cremations than
they're usually allowed to do
oh boy david i'm very sorry to hear that
thank you very much